We can change the radio station
when we hear songs that treat women as nothing.
We can spend our box office dollars elsewhere
when movies don't treat women
as anything more than decorative objects.
We can stop supporting professional sports
where the athletes treat their partners like punching bags.
(Applause)
In other ways, men -- and especially straight white men --
can say, "No, I will not publish with your magazine,
or participate in your project, or otherwise work with you,
until you include a fair number of women,
both as participants and decision makers.
I won't work with you until your publication,
or your organization, is more inclusive of all kinds of difference."
Those of us who are underrepresented
and invited to participate in such projects,
can also decline to be included
until more of us are invited through the glass ceiling,
and we are tokens no more.
Without these efforts,
without taking these stands,
our accomplishments are going to mean very little.
We can commit these small acts of bravery
and hope that our choices trickle upward to the people in power --
editors, movie and music producers,
CEOs, lawmakers --
the people who can make bigger, braver choices
to create lasting, meaningful change.
We can also boldly claim our feminism --
good, bad, or anywhere in between.
The last line of my book "Bad Feminist" says,
"I would rather be a bad feminist than no feminist at all."
This is true for so many reasons,
but first and foremost, I say this because once upon a time,
my voice was stolen from me,
and feminism helped me to get my voice back.
There was an incident.
I call it an incident so I can carry the burden of what happened.
Some boys broke me,
when I was so young, I did not know
what boys can do to break a girl.
They treated me like I was nothing.
I began to believe I was nothing.
They stole my voice, and in the after,
I did not dare to believe
that anything I might say could matter.
But --
I had writing.
And there, I wrote myself back together.
I wrote myself toward a stronger version of myself.
I read the words of women
who might understand a story like mine,
and women who looked like me,
and understood what it was like to move through the world with brown skin.
I read the words of women who showed me I was not nothing.
I learned to write like them,
and then I learned to write as myself.
I found my voice again,
and I started to believe that my voice is powerful beyond measure.
Through writing and feminism,
I also found that if I was a little bit brave,
another woman might hear me and see me and recognize
that none of us are the nothing the world tries to tell us we are.
In one hand,
I hold the power to accomplish anything.
And in my other,
I hold the humbling reality that I am just one woman.
I am a bad feminist,
I am a good woman,
I am trying to become better in how I think,
and what I say, and what I do,
without abandoning everything that makes me human.
I hope that we can all do the same.
I hope that we can all be a little bit brave,
when we most need such bravery.
(Applause)